大家欢迎回来
来上 FP101x
让我们现在开始吧
首先介绍一点函数式程序设计的历史
当我们看 Java 或 JavaScript 这样的语言时
很容易忘记函数式程序设计的概念
实际上非常古老
甚至是在我们大多数人出生之前就被发明了
这位是阿隆佐·邱奇（Alonzo Church）
他在20世纪30年代发明了 lambda 演算
他是打算将 lambda 演算作为数学的基础的
他想要找到一种方式
来描述数学的基础
结果令人惊奇的是
他在20世纪30年代的工作
成为了今天大多数编程语言的基础
如果你去看 JavaScript 这门支撑起万维网的语言
我们都知道在 JavaScript 中函数很重要
所以人们可以说
是 lambda 演算支持着万维网
现在 Java 8 也有 lambda 表达式 C++
也有 lambda 表达式 如今正在使用的编程语言没有一门
不支持阿隆佐·丘奇
在20世纪30年代发明的这个概念
如果再靠近现代一点
20世纪50年代，约翰·麦卡锡
发明了 Lisp 语言 这是最早几门编程语言之一
它同时也是第一个 函数式编程语言 约翰·麦卡锡（John McCarthy）
受 lambda 演算影响 但他也同时
也在 Lisp 中设计了过程式的赋值
在某种程度上你可以说 Lisp 是最早的 几门现代语言之一
它结合了纯 lambda 演算的思想 以及一些编程语言中的过程式特性
在20世纪60年代 彼得·兰丁发明了 ISWIM
意思是 如果你知道我的意思是什么（If You See What I Mean）
它是第一个纯函数式语言
基于 lambda 演算 这也意味着
语言中没有赋值 只有纯函数
20世纪70年代 约翰·巴科斯（John Backus） 设计了 FP 意思是
函数式编程（Functional Programming） 约翰·巴科斯
同时也是 Fortran 的设计者之一
那门语言大约是和 Lisp 同时设计出来的
是一门过程特性十分强的语言
他在七十年代设计了这门新语言
强调高阶函数
并特别强调对程序进行推理
希望能够推理得出 FP 代码的正确性
FP 对这点十分强调 同样在七十年代
这边的这位罗宾·米尔纳（Robin Milner）
发明了 ML 编程语言
ML 同样是一门混合式编程语言
既包含纯函数编程语言的思想
又允许过程式赋值
关于 ML 的一个有趣的细节是
ML 最初的设计目标是一门脚本语言
它被设计成能让人们写出证明的脚本
当你写下数学证明时 有很多地方只是套用模板
需要很多步骤 为了让这一过程自动化
米尔纳和他的同事发明了 ML
来让你能够用脚本完成无聊的步骤
ML 有一个优点 记住当时是七十年代
它就支持类型推断了
因此你可以写下一个函数 编译器就会帮你推断出类型
ML 同时也有多态类型 或者我们现在所谓的
泛型 比如你可以有一个 T 类型的列表
之后将 T 实例化为整数类型或字符串类型
甚至是另一个列表类型 这些类型推断的概念
以及泛型的概念实际上都很古老
过了几十年后这些概念才从学术界进入主流
在七八十年代 大卫·特纳（David Turner）
设计了多门编程语言 开始是 SASL
接着是 KRC 最终的顶点是
Miranda 这些都是惰性函数式语言
我们将在后面看到惰性函数式语言
和严格的函数式语言的区别
大卫·特纳极具影响力
因为 Haskell 这门我们的课中要用的编程语言
同样是惰性语言 它是基于
大卫·特纳在 Miranda SASL 和 KRC
上所做的很多工作 当我开始学计算机科学时
在八十年代 接触到的第一门函数式语言
就是 SASL 所以 SASL 在我心中一直有特别的地位
我们也会在之后的课程中了解一下 SASL
因为在某种程度上 SASL 是 Haskell 之母
现在说说 Haskell 大约 1987 年
一些编程语言研究者和函数式语言研究者
开始设计 Haskell 语言 想法就是
设计一门人们可以在上面进行试验的标准语言
因为如果你想试验一下 比方说 一种新的类型系统
搭建整个编程语言的框架需要做很多工作
比如语言本身 解析器 等等 尽管你想做的只是
研究这个新的类型系统
Haskell 有时被称为
编程语言研究的培养皿
它实现了这个目标 有很多研究论文
中 Haskell 被用作
实验的 基质 同时 Haskell 本身
作为一门编程语言也是十分成功的
Haskell 同时也是我们在这门课中使用的编程语言
2003年 有趣的是
发表的却是 Haskell 98 报告 也就是说设计完成已经过去了很多年
Haskell 98 的目的是定义这门编程语言的一个稳定版本
Haskell 作为一个研究工具
有着许多的扩展 为了使这门语言能够在主流中使用
需要的就是它的一个稳定版本
只包含那些一致且完成的特性
因此人们才能依靠它们
与此同时 Haskell 也在不断进化
但在这门课程中 我们只使用 Haskell 98 这一子集
如果你用的是 GHC 下一节课中将讲到 GHC 有许多扩展
但那是之后的话题了
我们将仅仅使用 Haskell 98
目前 Haskell 有 Haskell platform
供你下载 课程网站上有很多的相关信息
让你能用其他方式运行 Haskell 程序
以及其他语言的链接 可以用于完成练习
但是 Haskell platform 提供了一种 Haskell 语言的实现
外加针对 Windows Mac 和 Linux 这些主要平台的标准库
Haskell platform 在工业界广泛使用
用来设计真正的软件
同时我们也将看到
Haskell 对其他语言的影响
让我们用一小段 Haskell 程序作为这部分的结尾
来展示 Haskell 的简洁程度
这个程序 实现的是 使用快速排序算法对列表进行排序
这是代码 当我们完成几节课之后
你就能够自己写这样的代码了
当我们要对一个列表进行排序时 首先要看的是
如果列表是空表 也就是这里的第一种情况
我们对空表进行排序
结果仍然是空表 因为空表本身已经排好序了
接下来的一步是 如果我们有一个列表 xs
前面的值是 x
我们要做的是
首先把小于 x 的元素取出来
把它们放在名为 ys 的列表中 接下来
我们取出所有大于 x 的值 放在名为 zs 的列表中
接下来要做的就是递归地
用函数 f 来对 ys 进行排序
因此所有小于 x 的值都会被排序
接下来我们将大于 x 的值 也就是 zs 排序
接下来我们连接
这两个表 并把 x 放在中间
可以很容易看到
这个递归调用的结果
是我们现在有一个排好序的表了
提醒一下 这个程序
仅仅是想你展现快速排序算法的结构
它展现了递归分解的排序方式
真正的快速排序 在一门过程式的语言中
并不如此创建新的列表
也就是这两个表 相反 它会只用一个列表 并在原位置改变值
因此只使用一个列表的空间
即使如此 如果你想学习快速排序的算法结构
这个程序是十分优雅的
当然 我们可能以这个程序作为出发点 接下来我们想
实现一种更有效率的方式 通过改变状态
十分感谢 这就是第一节课的结尾了
祝你 Hacking 课程网站上的练习题愉快！
下周我们第二节课再见